[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's brief video we're going to be
discussing the weasleys
and of course once again the economic
status
more specifically we're going to be
addressing their level of wealth
and how it changed after winning the
wizarding lottery
was it enough to let them live
comfortably for the rest of their lives
was it enough for arthur to drop a
couple of hours at the ministry
let's dive into it now when we think of
the weasleys we certainly don't think of
wealth
we think of love friendship and unity
but one thing that's certainly drilled
into our heads throughout the harry
potter books and films
is that they don't have a lot of money
they're a big family
consisting of fred george charlie molly
arthur
ginny bill percy and of course ron which
means there are a lot of them to feed
clothe and house but money is evidently
scarce on molly and arthur's income
they were responsible for seven sets of
clothes and seven
mouths to feed eight if you include
harry's they had to cover a lot
their financial situation became so dire
that weasley almost became synonymous
with poor
something which draco so fondly reminded
them of whenever he had the chance
think my name's funny do you well no
need to ask yours
red hair to hand me down robe you must
be a weasley
arthur weasley ended up working for the
ministry of magic in multiple roles over
the years
first he worked for the misuse of muggle
artifacts department
a department responsible for regulating
the use of magic on muggle objects
as well as keeping bewitched items away
from muggles
later on he moved into position at the
detection and confiscation
of counterfeit defensive spells and
protective objects department
where he became head of office head of
office sounds like it would pay well
right why was money so scarce basically
arthur had a lot of amounts to feed a
lot of school supplies to buy
and some work issues that contributed to
this
you see in his first role arthur's boss
was cornelius fudge
who he did not get along with this
stunted his career progression
and ultimately the amount of money that
he was able to make
however in the summer of 1993 arthur and
molly got a bit of a break
when they won the wizarding lottery if
you don't know what the wizarding
lottery is
well it's just like our own lottery it's
hosted by the daily prophet
a wizarding newspaper based in london
that serves as the primary source of
news
for british and irish wizards the main
office for the daily prophet
is located right in diagon alley in
spite of the paper's dubious reputation
for publishing slanted content
at the request of cornelius fudge in the
ministry of magic there are certainly
some
good elements to the paper one of these
being the daily prophet grand prize
galleon draw an annual contest where
witches and wizards
can win some money in the summer of 1993
arthur weasley just so happened to win
the annual galleon draw
this is referenced by draco when
addressing ron i heard your father's got
his hands on some gold this summer
weasley did your mother die of shock
provided that even draco a stuck up
wealthy young wizard was able to
recognize the sum of money one
it tells me that the sun was at least
noteworthy arthur weasley was even able
to bring his entire family for a summer
trip to egypt to visit bill
so how much did he win as it turns out
arthur won about 700 gallons
it was with this money that he was able
to buy the trip to egypt as well as a
new one for his son ron
but how much is 700 gallons exactly
is that a lot a little did they still
have money left after the aforementioned
expenses
as reported by jk rowling one galleon
the largest form of wizarding currency
is said to be worth about five great
british pounds
that means that arthur won 3 500 pounds
which isn't anything to scoff at
but certainly isn't enough to last
forever wizarding economy doesn't seem
to differ much from
our own economy either apparently a copy
of advanced potion making
costs nine gallons which would be 45
pounds
a figure that is fairly consistent with
our own world
with all of that said arthur's winnings
were certainly a pleasant surprise
but nothing life-changing did you know
about the wizarding lottery
comment down below until next time your
wizard dowry
you